mushrooms are my thing I mean that they
enlightened me they straightened me out
they love me
but Allah but the way to do mushrooms is
the very first move if you're interested
in mushrooms is for god sake by a scale
by a scale I mean you wouldn't think
that this would be considered such an
exotic suggestion to people who are
going to put their bodies and minds on
the line because people don't take
enough people do not take enough
mushrooms they take pissant amounts and
then they claim that their initiates you
must take a measured five dried grams on
an empty stomach measured and when you
see what that is you'll realize that you
know you aren't even camped in the
atrium you are camped in the driveway
and mushrooms to my in some ways I mean
DMT is the most terrifying an
astonishing thing in the universe but
it's very hard to know what to do
psilocybin is your friend it wants to
teach it will take you by the hand and
forgive you and lead you and be with you
and it's speaks this is the amazing
thing and you're hearing this from you
know somebody who graduated from
Heidegger and FH Bradley it speaks no
other psychedelic does that in my
experience occasionally a phrase will
pop into your head on another substance
that is like a gift an aphorism but I
mean psilocybin raves it raves and it
has positions I mean you may not like
psilocybin as a person because it is not
if the astonishing thing about the
psilocybin entity it to my mind and I
get good confirmation of this is it is
not very earthly
I mean it wants to show you machines the
size of Manhattan in orbit around alien
stars it wants to talk about the sweep
through of the little de which happened
before the earth cooled and if you know
has seen the empires of the roll out at
the rim and all the rest of it and it's
very puzzling this cosmic Galactic Aryan
tone because then you switch over to
ayahuasca which is literally just a
twist to the molecule just tiniest
tweaking of the molecule and suddenly
it's about childbirth rivers the land
the feminine looking inside your body
curing disease
feeling telepathy communication it could
hardly be more different and yet
chemically these things are like to two
sides of the same coin
yes first come the dancing my the little
candies the colored grids and so forth
and so on but what eventually happens
quickly like 10 minutes later is there
is an entity in the trance in the vision
there is a mind there waiting that
speaks good English and invites you up
into its room what it is is it's a voice
in the head that people strove to attain
for a thousand years this was the semi
qua non of intellectual accomplishment
in the greco-roman world and the logos
told you the right way to live and this
is sort of what you get with psilocybin
you get a voice that can confound you
with the depth and brilliance of the
dancers this is what you want and I've
had over and over the experience of
showing somebody what 5 grams is and
they're appalled
they say my god you can't be serious I
mean I would I take a fifth that much a
fourth that much yeah well that's the
problem that's why you Devils in the
attic and bats in the belfry light on
you
a lot of people have said you're a
hallucination not you're obsessed with
hallucination I freely admit it
but I will defend my obsession with
vision I think the world wants to be
seen I think Blake was right that the
divine imagination is something beheld
and for me the visions are the proof
that this is not my mind and the visions
are the proof that this is not simply
chemical chaos and the nervous system
and when we communicate with each other
and understand each other we
instinctively reach for visual metaphors
I see what you mean
look here Noah she painted a picture his
words were so beautiful it means that we
really associate meaning with seeing
something